[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gens c'est parti aujourd'hui je suis
avec un jeune débutant un jeune chef en
cuisine bonjour Monsieur Philippe
Etchebest bonjour on va cuisiner des
repas protéinés tu vas c'est pas moi tu
vas te régaler Philippe à tout à l'heure
moi
dans le secteur de l'aéroport de dognac
et depuis une heure maintenant on entend
vraiment d'intenses tir à l'arme lourde
et des tirs de mitrailleuses
automatiques là au bout de cette rue
derrière cette barre d'immeuble les
forces ukrainiennes sont
apparemment à 2 km et les séparatistes
essaient de reprendre de repousser les
forces
ukrainiennes au-delà parce que ici c'est
un point stratégique qui ouvre la voie à
toutes les routes vers le don basse
depuis toute petite ma piste préférée
c'est celle là
une piste verte qui est longue qui est
dans les sapins et à l'époque je ne
savais pas que c'était une piste de
super-héros voilà et ça c'est trop cool
six Seb
[Musique]
pour la couleur de mes chaussettes mon
fait sourire mon profil athénien
on a
tu peux sourire s'il te plaît
ou pas j'espère on est comme ça en tout
cas si ça vous plaît pas vous savez qui
vous met une droite
[Rires]
[Musique]